From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
OK. So we're going through the gate here into the park?
好的。那我们现在正穿过大门进入公园吗？
Yeah, we're going-- this is our morning-- this is the morning walk into the park. See, everybody will split up into their different sections and get the park open. And we'll start putting out prizes and--
是的，我们正要去——这是我们的早晨——这是进入公园的晨间漫步。看，每个人都会分散到各自的区域，准备开园。我们一会儿就开始摆放奖品，然后……
We're at an amusement park in Kansas City, Missouri called Worlds of Fun. We're going to be spending the entire hour today at amusement parks. It's five minutes before opening, and I'm walking with Cole Lindbergh, who's 25 with permanently-mussed hair and the cheerful vibe of the Bosom Buddies-era Tom Hanks. He's been coming to this park since he was a little kid, started working here as a summer job at 14, and then basically just never left. It became his real job. 11 years later, he is a full-time, year-round employee.
我们现在在密苏里州堪萨斯城的“欢乐世界”游乐园。今天整个小时我们都将在游乐园度过。距离开园还有五分钟，我正和25岁的科尔·林德伯格同行，他头发总是乱糟糟的，有着《肥佬教授》时代汤姆·汉克斯那种开朗的气质。他从小就来这个公园玩，14岁时在这里做暑期工，之后基本上就没离开过。这份工作成了他的正职。11年后，他成了一名全职的全年雇员。
I love amusement parks. Any time my family would go on vacation, we'd schedule it around an amusement park, because I love roller coasters. I loved amusement parks. I mean, I've walked-- this pathway that we're taking right now-- I've walked it thousands and thousands and thousands of times.
我爱游乐园。每当家人去度假，我们总会把游乐园排进日程，因为我喜欢过山车。我热爱游乐园。我的意思是，我走过——我们现在走的这条路——我走过成千上万次了。
When he was little, his family had season passes here, and they would come a lot. He'd travel to any new roller coaster to try it out, daydreamed about a job where he would design parks and build roller coasters. And when his dad drove him here at the age of 14 for a job interview-- he wore a suit to that interview-- just sitting inside the park's offices, which are utilitarian-- picture the principal's office at a public high school-- even that was exciting.
他小时候，家里有这里的季票，他们常来。他会去尝试任何新的过山车，梦想着有一份设计公园和建造过山车的工作。当他14岁时父亲开车送他来面试——他穿了西装——坐在公园办公室里，那里很简朴——想象一下公立高中的校长办公室——即使那样也让他感到兴奋。
I remember being like, oh, wow. This is the inner sanctum. This is the inner workings. This is where all the cool stuff happens. And then the first time actually getting in the uniform, actually working at the park-- I remember, to me, it was like, wow. This is surreal. I'm actually working in an amusement park now. And to me, that was kind of, like, awesome. That was awesome. I'm so excited about this.
我记得当时心想，哇。这是核心区域。这是内部运作机制。这就是酷事发生的地方。然后第一次穿上制服，真正开始在公园工作时——我记得，对我来说，就像，哇。这太超现实了。我竟然真的在游乐园工作了。对我来说，那感觉真是太棒了。太棒了。我对此感到非常兴奋。
You might think that enthusiasm would diminish over time. But what's incredible about Cole is that, even after a decade here, even after becoming an adult and working 60-, 70-hour weeks, every week, all summer, even with the pressure in his current job of running a whole department and hitting financial targets and buying all the supplies and hiring and supervising over 100 young people, he is still pretty psyched about working at an amusement park.
你可能认为这种热情会随着时间推移而消退。但科尔不可思议的地方在于，即使在这里待了十年，即使已经成年并每周工作60到70个小时，整个夏天都如此，即使还要承受目前管理整个部门、达到财务目标、采购所有用品、雇用并监管100多名年轻人的压力，他依然对在游乐园工作感到非常兴奋。
And it is not a glamour job. The department Cole runs is the games department at Worlds of Fun. This is 32 games, the kind that you would see at any carnival or midway, where you get three softballs to try to throw them into a milk can, or you throw beanbags at targets, or you shoot darts to knock over a stack of cups.
但这并不是一份光鲜的工作。科尔管理的部门是“欢乐世界”的游艺项目部。这里有32个游戏，就是你在任何嘉年华或游乐场都能看到的那些，比如给你三个垒球尝试投进奶罐，或者向目标投掷豆袋，又或者是扔飞镖击倒一堆杯子。
Nobody comes to an amusement park for the games. Cole himself never went to an amusement park for the games. But he's an extrovert, and he has filled the department with extroverts, like Mallory. The park is barely open-- hardly any customers here at all-- when Cole stops by her game on his morning rounds.
没人是为了玩游戏才来游乐园的。科尔本人以前来游乐园也不是为了玩这些游戏。但他是个外向的人，他也为部门招募了像马洛里这样外向的员工。公园刚开门——几乎没什么游客——科尔在晨间巡视时顺便去了她的摊位。
Yeah, Mallory loves talking on the mic. Mallory does a good job on the mic.
是啊，马洛里很喜欢用麦克风说话。马洛里用麦克风的表现很不错。
(WHISPERING) Thank you! I appreciate it.
（耳语）谢谢！我很感激。
Let's hear it. Go for it. Try to get people to play.
让我们听听看。开始吧。试着拉人来玩。
All righty. We're over here at three-point challenge today looking for out first winner! You come on over here. You have 40 seconds on the clock, 12 shots up, and you could be walking away with some awesome prizes! We have--
好的。我们今天在“三分投篮挑战”这里寻找第一位赢家！快过来。你有40秒时间，投12球，你就有机会赢走超级棒的奖品！我们有……
This is exactly how Cole trains the kids to talk on the mic. Don't stop. Get a flow. Have fun. If you have fun, that's what's going to sell the game. Watching Cole run the games department at Worlds of Fun is watching somebody who was raised here and who completely, thoroughly mastered everything. It's rare to witness somebody so happily great at any job.
这就是科尔如何训练孩子们使用麦克风的。不要停。保持节奏。玩得开心。如果你玩得开心，那就能卖出游戏。看科尔管理“欢乐世界”的游艺部门，就像看着一个在这里长大并完全、彻底掌握了一切的人。能看到有人如此快乐且出色地完成工作，这很罕见。
All right. Let's gather around, guys. Is there still people in cash patrol? Anybody know?
好了。大家聚过来。还有人在“现金巡逻队”吗？有人知道吗？
It's the first shift meeting of the day. About 30 teenagers and college kids mill around a big tree before their shifts start.
这是当天第一次轮班会议。大约30名青少年和大学生在轮班开始前围着一棵大树聚集。
All right, guys. Listen up. Gather round. Let's do this. Here we go. Shh. Quiet, please. Real quick. Real quick. Here we go. Today is Saturday.
好了，伙计们。听着。围过来。我们开始吧。来吧。嘘。安静点，请。快点。快点。我们开始吧。今天是星期六。
Oh, yeah!
哦，耶！
Today is a busy day. Today is the day that we have a very good day, because there are going to be a lot of people playing games. And today, of course, is one of my favorite days of the season. It is the second round of the Sweet 16 Tournament. Let's take a look. Sam, do you want to hold this up a little higher? OK. We've got--
今天是个忙碌的日子。今天注定会是很棒的一天，因为会有很多人来玩游戏。当然，今天也是我本赛季最喜欢的日子之一。今天是“甜蜜16强”锦标赛的第二轮。我们来看看。萨姆，你能把这个举高一点吗？好。我们有……
One of the guys, Sam, holds up a poster board with tournament brackets on it, like for any sports tournament. The Sweet 16 Tournament pits the kids in all 32 games in the park against each other, in pairs, in a four-week competition to make the most money. Last week, half the games were eliminated. Cole is here letting the remaining games know who they're competing with today.
其中一个伙计萨姆举起一张带有锦标赛对阵表的宣传板，就像任何体育赛事那样。“甜蜜16强”锦标赛让公园里所有32个游戏的员工两两配对，在为期四周的比赛中争夺最高营收。上周，一半的游戏被淘汰了。科尔在这里通知剩余的游戏组今天他们的对手是谁。
We have Pigs of Fury, Bullpen versus Goblet Toss, Lion's Den. Now-- can you hold that for me real quick? Now-- wait, hold on! Before we go any further, could this possibly be a precursor for today? Yesterday, the number-one game in the park was Scale Africa.
我们有“愤怒之猪”、“牛棚”对阵“高脚杯投掷”、“狮穴”。现在——你能帮我拿一下这个吗？现在——等等，等一下！在我们继续之前，这会不会是今天的预兆？昨天，公园里排名第一的游戏是“非洲秤重”。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
OK. Scale Africa is a scale-- a game where they guess your weight or age. And it's in the Africa part of the park, hence Scale Africa. And it's no surprise that it's number one. It always makes tons of money. All the games in the park are grouped together into four different teams, which they call Games I, Games II, Games III, and Games IV. And these four teams-- Games I through IV-- compete against each other all summer long, like teams at summer camp, in a three-month-long color war.
好。“非洲秤重”是一个秤——一个猜测你体重或年龄的游戏。它在公园的非洲区，所以叫“非洲秤重”。它排名第一并不奇怪。它总是能赚很多钱。公园里所有的游戏被分成四个不同的组，他们称之为游戏I、游戏II、游戏III和游戏IV。这四个组——游戏I到IV——整个夏天都在相互竞争，就像夏令营的队伍，进行为期三个月的颜色大战。
Most other amusement parks don't go this far to make things interesting for the workers. This park, Worlds of Fun, is owned by a company called Cedar Fair that owns 11 amusement parks and six water parks. And Cole knows the guys who run the games departments at the other parks. And some of them do competitions like this between the employees.
大多数其他游乐园不会为了让员工觉得有趣而做到这一步。这个“欢乐世界”公园由雪松会公司拥有，该公司拥有11个游乐园和6个水上乐园。科尔认识其他公园游艺部门的管理人员。他们中的一些人也确实在员工之间搞过这种竞赛。
But I don't think they do it to the extent of what we do. Yeah, we-- every year, I talk about-- we had the Death Match Tournament. We have the Sweet 16 Tournament.
但我觉得他们没做到我们这种程度。是的，我们……每年，我说的是……我们有“死斗锦标赛”。我们有“甜蜜16强”锦标赛。
A couple years ago, we did a thing called Toss the Boss. And basically what happened was is that, every single day, I'd pull a game out of the hat. And if that game was the number-one game in the park for that day, then that section would get to throw me in the pond. The pond is not a good-looking pond. It's gross, and it smells. And the deal was is that, if you are the number-one game in the park, you get to throw me in the pond.
几年前，我们搞了一个叫“扔老板”的活动。基本上就是，每天我会从帽子里抽出一个游戏。如果那个游戏当天是公园里的第一名，那么那一组就可以把我扔进池塘。那个池塘看起来不怎么样。它很恶心，还有臭味。规矩就是，如果你是公园第一名的游戏，你就可以把我扔进池塘。
So finally, one day, the game that he picked from the hat that day tried their hardest and actually became the number-one game in the park for the day. And--
终于有一天，他从帽子里抽出的那组游戏拼尽全力，真的成为了当天公园里的第一名。然后……
Ready?
准备好了吗？
1, 2, 3!
1，2，3！
[SPLASH]
（水花声）
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
D'oh!
哎呀！
Of course, they made a video about this because it's present-day America. And Cole went and told his peers, his colleagues-- the guys who run the games departments at the other parks-- all about what happened.
当然，他们拍了视频，因为这就是当今的美国。科尔把发生的事告诉了他的同行，他的同事们——那些在其他公园管理游艺部门的人。
I go and I tell the other parks about this. And I showed a picture. Like, oh, there's me all soaking wet. And I got laughed at. Like, why would you ever do that? And to me, in my mind, I was just like, why would you not do that? Why would you not want to get people excited about working in the game that they're in? At least they may try. They may do a little bit more. And if I can get a little bit more out of them, we're good, even if the game only makes a little bit more money.
我去告诉其他公园这件事。我还展示了照片。就像，哦，看我全身湿透的样子。结果我被嘲笑了。他们问，你为什么要那样做？而在我心里，我只是觉得，为什么不呢？为什么不想让大家对自己负责的游戏感到兴奋呢？至少他们可能会去尝试。他们可能会多做一点。如果我能从他们身上多榨出一点点，我们就赚到了，哪怕那个游戏只多赚了一点钱。
Also, it's more fun for the kids.
而且，这对孩子们来说也更有趣。
Exactly. It's all about more fun.
没错。一切都是为了更有趣。
All right. So there's a lot of people in the park today. Now, I have composed a song about today, which I now want to sing for you.
好了。今天公园里人很多。现在，我写了一首关于今天的歌，我打算现在唱给你们听。
Everybody close--
大家靠近……
And you can all sing along. [STRUMS GUITAR] OK. (SINGING) Saturday. It's Saturday, Saturday, Saturday, Saturday.
你们都可以跟着唱。（弹吉他）好。（歌唱）星期六。今天是星期六，星期六，星期六，星期六。
So wait, what day is it? I forgot.
等等，今天是星期几？我忘了。
It's Saturday.
是星期六。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
(SINGING) Today, I don't feel like riding any rides.
（歌唱）今天，我不想去坐任何游乐设施。
Whistle, whistle.
口哨，口哨。
(SINGING) I just want to play all the games. And I really like playing Mamba Ball-- win a giant top frog or a big basketball. Yes, today, I don't feel like riding any rides, just playing games.
（歌唱）我只想玩所有的游戏。我真的很喜欢玩曼巴球——赢一只巨大的青蛙或一个大篮球。是的，今天，我不想坐游乐设施，只想玩游戏。
(SINGING) Whoo-hoo! Whoo! Whoo-hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo!
（歌唱）喔呜！喔！喔呜，呜，呜，呜，呜，呜！
All right. Let's have a good day, guys. Everybody in, all right?
好了。祝大家今天过得愉快，伙计们。所有人，准备好了吗？
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
All right. Games on three! 1, 2, 3!
好。数到三就喊“游戏”！1，2，3！
Games!
游戏！
All right. Let's have a good day.
好。祝大家度过愉快的一天。
Well, today, on our radio show, we go to amusement parks all over the country. We see stuff backstage that we had no idea was going on, like that song. We hear Jonathan Goldstein's story about moving to the Jersey Shore for a summer when he was 16, and we hear your stories. We asked you to call in with your amusement park stories, and you told some great ones.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将前往全国各地的游乐园。我们看到了我们完全不知道发生的幕后事情，比如那首歌。我们将听到乔纳森·戈尔茨坦关于16岁那年搬到新泽西海岸度过一个夏天的故事，也会听到你们的故事。我们曾邀请你们打来电话分享你们的游乐园故事，你们讲了一些非常棒的故事。
Today's show was recorded and first broadcast a few years ago when you could attend amusement parks without wearing a face mask or taking precautions to avoid a deadly and deeply-contagious coronavirus. Let us return to those happy days, shall we? It's summer. It's hot. Let's spend an hour at a really fun place at a safe social distance-- in fact, the safest imaginable-- that is, over the radio. Let's ride the rides. Let's gorge out on terrible great food together for an hour. Cue the roller coaster sound now!
今天的节目是在几年前录制并首次播出的，那时候你们可以去游乐园而无需戴口罩或采取预防措施来避免致命且具有高度传染性的冠状病毒。让我们回到那些快乐的日子，好吗？夏天到了。天气很热。让我们在一个非常有趣的地方花一个小时，保持安全的社交距离——事实上，是能想象到的最安全的方式——那就是，通过无线电。让我们去坐游乐设施吧。让我们一起花一个小时大吃特吃那些糟糕但美味的食物。现在播放过山车的声音！
[ROLLER COASTER SOUND]
（过山车声音）
Stay with us.
留下来陪我们。
Act One. Gameboy Grows Up. Following Cole Lindbergh around on his early-morning tour of Words of Fun park, I learned a couple things. First of all, people play the games because they want to win the prizes. And so an important part of his job is actually guessing what prizes are going to excite people.
第一幕。游戏男孩长大了。跟随着科尔·林德伯格参观“欢乐世界”公园的清晨之旅，我学到了几件事。首先，人们玩游戏是因为他们想赢奖品。所以他工作的一个重要部分其实是猜测什么样的奖品会让人兴奋。
We kind of just go, it is what it is. Oh, I've got to show you the lemur. Do you want to see what a lemur is?
我们基本上就是，顺其自然。哦，我得让你看看狐猴。你想看看狐猴是什么吗？
Yeah.
好啊。
People love these. This is a lemur. People play for this all the time. This is one of our number-one prizes.
人们喜欢这些。这就是狐猴。人们总是为了这个玩游戏。这是我们排名第一的奖品之一。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Who'd have thought? It's a fluorescent-colored monkey, the size of a teddy bear, with huge eyes and a super-long tail. When they put it into the dart game, the dart game became one of the most popular games in the park-- doubled its business. I also learned that Cole invents games.
谁能想到呢？这是一只荧光色的猴子，有泰迪熊那么大，眼睛很大，还有一条超长的尾巴。当他们把它放进飞镖游戏时，飞镖游戏成了公园里最受欢迎的游戏之一——生意翻了一倍。我还了解到科尔会发明游戏。
You like Angry Birds, right?
你喜欢《愤怒的小鸟》，对吧？
We round a corner and I see why he asked.
我们绕过拐角，我明白了为什么他会这么问。
What we're looking at right now is a giant slingshot with a launcher that you launch, basically, beanbags at pigs. And we built this.
我们现在看到的是一个巨大的弹弓发射器，你基本上是用它发射豆袋去打猪。这个是我们自己造的。
So you got permission from the Angry Birds people--
所以你得到了《愤怒的小鸟》版权方的许可……
Well--
嗯……
This turns out to be an awkward question. Cole points out that this slingshot game is not actually called Angry Birds.
这成了一个尴尬的问题。科尔指出，这个弹弓游戏其实并不叫《愤怒的小鸟》。
It's called Pigs of Fury-- Pigs of Fury. So now this is one of our number-one games. People love shooting a giant slingshot.
它叫“愤怒之猪”——“愤怒之猪”。所以现在这是我们排名第一的游戏。人们喜欢用巨大的弹弓射击。
Before I flew out to Kansas City to meet Cole, I watched his YouTube videos online. Yes, he has YouTube videos, and I heartily recommend them. They are shot, directed, and starring Cole. They are low-tech. They're low-budget. In this one, he wears a Viking helmet, and a fake mustache, and wire-rimmed glasses. And he's walking through a video arcade. Those are his echoey footsteps that you're hearing.
在我飞往堪萨斯城见科尔之前，我上网看了他的YouTube视频。是的，他有YouTube视频，我强烈推荐它们。它们由科尔拍摄、导演并主演。它们低科技、低预算。在这个视频里，他戴着维京头盔、假胡子和铁丝框眼镜。他正走过一个游戏厅。你听到的就是他那回响的脚步声。
Next, he's inside what looks like-- you know those old arcade machines with the mechanical claw that picks up prizes? This one is big enough for a person to stand inside, and Cole is inside it, surrounded by huge stuffed animals. And he raps.
接下来，他在一个看起来像……你知道那种带机械爪抓奖品的老式游戏机吗？这一个大到可以容纳一个人站在里面，科尔就在里面，周围堆满了巨大的毛绒动物。然后他开始饶舌。
(RAPPING) I give out prizes when you come play my games. If you see me with a mic, I guess it's your birthday. I'm a really cool guy because I make winners every day. Win a bear, a dog, and a giant mon-kay.
（饶舌）当你来玩我的游戏时，我就送出奖品。如果你看到我拿着麦克风，我想那是你的生日。我真是个酷家伙，因为我每天都在制造赢家。赢一只熊，一只狗，还有一只巨大的猴子。
OK, I'm going to stop the video right there. When he says "a bear, a dog, and a giant mon-kay," then we have three quick shots of stuffed animal prizes-- a bear, a dog, and a giant mon-kay.
好了，视频就停在这儿。当他说“一只熊，一只狗，还有一只巨大的猴子”时，我们会有三个毛绒奖品的快速镜头——一只熊，一只狗，还有一只巨大的猴子。
(RAPPING) Sometimes people just don't play games. I'm asking how they're doing, and they say, "No way!"
（饶舌）有时人们就是不玩游戏。我问他们怎么样，他们说，“没门！”
As the video continues, the teenagers on his staff join him. And they're all dancing around, and they're hitting whack-a-mole moles on the beat. And everything that they do in this video is so deeply uncool that you know that they must really like and trust each other. And their total commitment to what they're doing actually flips the dorkiness and makes it cool.
随着视频继续，他的员工里的青少年也加入了。他们围着跳舞，随着节奏拍打着地鼠。视频里他们所做的一切都非常不酷，这让你知道他们肯定非常喜欢并信任彼此。他们对所做之事的全力投入实际上消解了书呆子气，反而让它变得很酷。
(RAPPING) Get it in the can. Get this ball right in that can. You can do it, man. Just get this ball right in that can, because all I want to do is--
（饶舌）把它投进罐子里。把球投进那个罐子里。你能做到的，伙计。把球投进那个罐子里，因为我只想……
[GUNSHOTS]
（枪声）
[MUSIC - "PAPER PLANES" BY MIA]
（音乐 - M.I.A.的《Paper Planes》）
(RAPPING) And--
（饶舌）然后……
[CLICK]
（点击声）
[CHA-CHING]
（收银机声）
(SINGING) Come play my games.
（歌唱）来玩我的游戏。
[MUSIC - "PAPER PLANES" BY MIA]
（音乐 - M.I.A.的《Paper Planes》）
(RAPPING) All I wanna do is--
（饶舌）我只想……
[GUNSHOTS]
（枪声）
--and--
……然后……
[CLICK]
（点击声）
[CHA-CHING]
（收银机声）
(RAPPING) Come play my games.
（饶舌）来玩我的游戏。
[MUSIC - "PAPER PLANES" BY MIA]
（音乐 - M.I.A.的《Paper Planes》）
(RAPPING) All I wanna--
（饶舌）我只想……
There are over a dozen videos, all set in the amusement park, with the stuffed animal prizes always playing surprisingly central roles, like the sci-fi special effects movie they made where a mysterious ray from outer space hits, and the stuffed animal prizes all come to life, seeking vengeance. Key line?
视频有十几部，背景都在游乐园，毛绒玩具奖品总是扮演令人惊讶的核心角色，比如他们制作的那部科幻特效片，一颗来自外太空的神秘射线击中这里，毛绒奖品全部活了过来，寻求复仇。关键台词？
The prizes attacked me. I was in my game. The earth shook. And next thing I knew, I was being pummelled by bears!
奖品攻击了我。我当时在游戏里。大地在震动。接着我就发现自己被熊群痛扁！
The only semi-normal video of the bunch is a training video. This one opens on Cole. He's in a suit and tie in front of a bookcase, reading a book.
这堆视频里唯一半正常的是一个培训视频。这个视频以科尔开场。他穿着西装打着领带，站在书柜前读书。
[FORMAL ORCHESTRAL MUSIC PLAYING]
（正式管弦乐响起）
He looks up, startled, as if the camera surprised him.
他惊讶地抬起头，好像摄像头吓了他一跳。
Hello. How are you? I was just reading. Welcome to the World of Fun Games Training Video. My name is Cole. I'll be taking you on this wonderful journey. Here.
你好。你好吗？我刚才在读书。欢迎观看“欢乐世界”游戏培训视频。我的名字叫科尔。我将带你踏上这段美妙的旅程。来。
When he says "wonderful journey," he mugs at the camera with this gesture that communicates the idea "I know this is completely ridiculous." In fact, the entire video seems to be making fun of the idea of training videos while, at the same time, it is a training video, explaining how to sign in, how to use the till card, how to stock prizes. I saw these videos, and all I could think of was, these people really love their jobs. And I thought about Michael Scott, the fictional boss on The Office.
当他说“美妙的旅程”时，他对着镜头做了个鬼脸，传达出“我知道这完全荒谬”的意思。事实上，整个视频似乎在嘲笑培训视频这个概念，与此同时，它又确实是一个解释如何签到、如何使用收银机、如何补货奖品的培训视频。我看了这些视频，想到的全是，这些人真的非常热爱他们的工作。我联想到了迈克尔·斯科特，电视剧《办公室》里的虚构老板。
I'd say that there's a lot of Michael Scott in this job. I'd say there's a lot of Michael Scott in me, probably. I do silly things that everybody looks at me later and go, why did he do that? Why was it deemed necessary for Cole to dress up wearing a big beard and a raincoat, and tell everyone he lived downtown under the bridge and he was there to motivational speaker them today? (GRAVELLY VOICE) "Hi, everybody. I'm Phil Bridges"-- and go out and talk to people. What went through his thought process?
我会说这份工作里有很多迈克尔·斯科特的影子。我想我也很有迈克尔·斯科特的成分。我做一些傻事，过后每个人看着我都会问，他为什么那么做？为什么科尔打扮成戴着大胡子、穿着雨衣的样子，告诉大家他住在市中心桥下，他是来给他们做励志演讲的是必须的？（粗糙的声音）“嗨，大家好。我是菲尔·布里奇斯”——然后出去和人交谈。他的心路历程是什么？
And I've run out with a squirt gun all the time. I got my big Super Soaker. And on busy days, I'll take the Super Soaker, and I'll fill it up with ice water, and I'll sneak around the corner and just-- they're all standing there, and I'll just go, "light them up!" and just spray across the whole group.
我经常带着水枪跑出来。我有我的大水枪。在忙碌的日子里，我会带上大水枪，装满冰水，然后潜伏在拐角，等他们都站在那儿，我就喊：“干掉他们！”然后朝整群人喷过去。
That's what makes it fun! They're going to remember Phil Bridges more than anything else throughout the day. And so if they're talking about, "Did you guys see what Cole did at the shift meeting?" even if they say "that was stupid" or "that was not funny," they're still going to be talking about it. And that's still going to get them happy about this job.
这才是乐趣所在！比起其他任何事，他们会更记得菲尔·布里奇斯。所以如果他们在谈论，“你们看到科尔在晨会上干了什么吗？”，即使他们说“那很蠢”或“一点都不好笑”，他们也还是会谈论它。而这依然能让他们对这份工作感到开心。
So does that work in practice? After all, if you think about it, amusement park jobs are not, on their face, very fun, you know? Taking tickets, strapping people into rides, convincing passersby to throw three balls into a can.
那这在实践中有效吗？毕竟，如果你仔细想想，游乐园的工作表面上其实并不怎么有趣，对吧？检票，给游乐设施上的乘客扣安全带，说服路人把三个球投进罐子里。
Well, the Saturday that I visited turned out to be one of the busiest, hottest days of the summer. There was a concert at the park, which brought in thousands of extra people. And of course, this was Sweet 16 round two, which did seem to matter to the kids. Before the shift, Haley and a couple of the other kids from Games III pulled Cole aside and crowded close so kids from other teams couldn't see.
嗯，我去访的那天碰巧是夏天最忙、最热的日子之一。公园里有场演唱会，带进了成千上万的额外游客。当然，这是“甜蜜16强”第二轮，这对孩子们来说确实很重要。轮班前，海莉和“游戏III”组的其他几个孩子把科尔拉到一边，挤在一起，好让其他组的孩子看不到。
So this is-- you have a secret weapon that is going--
所以这是……你有一个秘密武器……
A secret weapon.
一个秘密武器。
They're going--
他们要……
Secret weapon.
秘密武器。
--to show you the secret weapon and what--
……展示给你看秘密武器，还有什么……
It's a--
是一个……
And don't let anybody see it.
别让任何人看到。
--guaranteed victory.
……保证胜利。
Guaranteed victory.
保证胜利。
It's a banana costume.
是一套香蕉服。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
So--
所以……
A banana.
香蕉。
--is that--
……这是……
You made the costume?
你做的这套衣服？
I made the costume, yeah.
是我做的，对。
Because she's awesome. Because we have a game with bananas that's in Sweet 16.
因为她太棒了。因为我们有一个带有香蕉的游戏，在“甜蜜16强”里。
That's right.
没错。
So we're going to have somebody running around in this costume to try to sell it.
所以我们打算让人穿着这身衣服四处跑，好试着推销它。
It's kind of big and it's kind of rough, because I didn't--
它有点大，也有点粗糙，因为我没有……
OK, I see.
好，我明白了。
--use a pattern.
……用纸样。
Wait, David's coming. Put it away. Put it away.
等等，戴维要来了。收起来。收起来。
Did you just go buy fabric?
你刚才去买布料了吗？
No, I've had this fabric. So this is the head hole, the arms hole. And it's going to look like the bananas in Lion's Den.
没有，我有这块布。所以这是头部开孔，这是手臂开孔。看起来会像“狮穴”里的香蕉。
I like it.
我喜欢。
We're pumped.
我们很激动。
Is that exciting?
那让人兴奋吗？
I like it. That is more than exciting.
我喜欢。那可不仅仅是让人兴奋。
People are going to be stopping, taking pictures. Oh, maybe I'll win one, too.
人们会停下脚步，拍照。哦，也许我也能赢一个。
Meanwhile, the guys in Games IV were doing great in Sweet 16. All their games had survived the first round. Games I was eliminated completely in the first round of Sweet 16. As for Games II, Max and Okson are pulling a double shift, hoping to break the record for how much has ever been made-- ever-- in their two games. Their not-so-secret strategy?
与此同时，“游戏IV”组在“甜蜜16强”里表现出色。他们所有的游戏都在第一轮中幸存了下来。“游戏I”在“甜蜜16强”第一轮中全军覆没。至于“游戏II”，马克斯和奥克森正在加倍轮班，希望打破他们两个游戏有史以来最高的营收记录。他们那并非那么保密的策略？
All right. So strobe light, strobe light. You want two blacklights out there.
好的。所以，频闪灯，频闪灯。你需要两个黑光灯放在外面。
Max and his team leader Dominic are setting up at a game called Roll-A-Ball, which is one of the older games in the park. Basically, it's just skee ball. But as you get points, it moves a little wooden pig, which is in a race with all the other riders.
马克斯和他的组长多米尼克正在设置一个叫“滚球”的游戏，这是公园里较老的游戏之一。基本上就是滚球游戏。但当你得分时，它会移动一个小木猪，和所有其他参赛者的木猪赛跑。
This doesn't make any sense. It actually doesn't matter. Here's what you need to know. Games II is hoping to turn this creaky, 16-year-old game Roll-A-Ball, which never does well, into a crazy dance party they call Techno Ball. Max and Dominic have brought in a disco ball. They brought in lighting gear. And Dominic is explaining to Max how he wants to set it all up.
这说不通。其实也没关系。你需要知道的是：游戏II希望把这个摇摇欲坠、16岁高龄、从来表现不佳的“滚球”游戏变成一个他们称之为“电音球”的疯狂舞会。马克斯和多米尼克带进了一个迪斯科球。他们带来了照明设备。多米尼克正向马克斯解释他想怎么设置。
You're going to put a light on that toy chest. You're going to put a light on that box. They're shining at the disco ball. The disco ball is going to be moving. If it's all dark in here, people will want to walk on it. They'll be like, "Whoa, what am I stepping on? Whoa, lights!" [LAUGHS]
你把灯放在那个玩具箱上。再把灯放在那个盒子上。它们要照在迪斯科球上。迪斯科球会转动。如果这里全黑，人们会想走上去。他们会觉得，“哇，我踩到什么了？哇，灯光！”（笑）
I know. Maybe it'll be too much for people to handle.
我知道。也许这对人们来说太刺激了。
Half an hour before the park opened, Haley and Claire had gotten to work early and were down in Games III by Scale Africa.
公园开门前半小时，海莉和克莱尔已经早早去上班，正在“游戏III”区，“非洲秤重”旁边。
We wanted to set out the most prizes that we could, make the piles extravagant, do a lot of flash. And that takes a lot of time. So we came out here early.
我们想摆出最多的奖品，让堆叠看起来奢华，多一点华丽感。这需要很多时间。所以我们早早就出来了。
So just describe what we're looking at. There's a pyramid here of--
那就描述一下我们看到了什么。这里有个金字塔，是……
Turtles. And there's pandas, lions. There's going to be one of tigers. There's going to be one--
乌龟。还有熊猫，狮子。会有一个老虎的。会有一个……
Each pyramid has over 100 stuffed animals in it, which is bigger than I think you're probably imagining it. It's nearly waist high. And so there are four big, pastel-colored piles of plush toys right in the middle of the walkway looking so, so easy to win. Basically--
每个金字塔有超过100个毛绒动物，比你想象的可能要大。它几乎到腰部那么高。所以人行道正中间有四个巨大的、柔和色调的毛绒玩具堆，看起来太容易赢了。基本上……
Every prize we've got.
我们所有的奖品。
Every prize we've got, yeah.
我们所有的奖品，是的。
We're throwing it out here.
我们要把它摆出来。
We're going big or go home. We really want to win.
我们要么做大，要么回家。我们真的很想赢。
We brought in streamers, balloons, energy drinks. We got a whole bunch of energy drinks. We got a whole bunch of Gatorade. We brought in food for everyone.
我们带来了彩带、气球、能量饮料。我们有一大堆能量饮料。我们有一大堆佳得乐。我们还带了食物给所有人。
--everyone stays energized, get pumped up for the whole day. We really want to win. We lost Death Match in a very painful battle.
……每个人都保持精力充沛，为整天打气。我们真的很想赢。我们在“死斗”中经历了一场痛苦的战斗才输掉。
Years ago, I was the lead of Games III. This was my section.
几年前，我是“游戏III”的负责人。这就是我的区域。
Cole gets just as excited as the kids do when you get him talking about all the fun things that he did back when he was Haley and Claire's age, working here, running Games III. His team would dress as pirates for the guessing game.
当科尔谈起他像海莉和克莱尔这个年纪，在这里工作、管理“游戏III”时做的那些趣事，他会变得和孩子们一样兴奋。他的队伍会装扮成海盗玩猜谜游戏。
And they'd be out at the scale, and they'd do guessing pirates. "Gaar, your age be-- gaar!" Stuff like that. 2004 came around-- we dominated. We beat everyone. It was awesome. [LAUGHS] And I-- so I'm--
他们会在秤边，玩猜谜海盗。“嗷，你的年龄是……嗷！”之类的。2004年来了——我们称霸了。我们打败了所有人。那太棒了。（笑）而我……所以我……
It is still so alive for him. They dominated in 2004 by tricking out one of the games with music, and all kinds of commotion, and turning it into a party, doubling its take for the day.
这对他的影响依然鲜活。2004年他们通过给其中一个游戏加装音乐和各种骚动，把它变成一场派对，当天营收翻倍，从而称霸。
We brought my fog machine in from home, because at the time, I was in high school and I had a band. And people flocked to it. And we destroyed Games II. We destroyed them that year. It was the happiest I'd been, because in 2003, we had gotten so close to winning. And I just kept on saying, 2004's the year. Games III. We're bringing the Sweet 16 back. 2004. And we did. We won. And I was really happy.
我从家里带来了雾气机，因为当时我还在上高中，组了个乐队。人们蜂拥而至。那一年我们摧毁了游戏II。我们摧毁了他们。那是我最快乐的时候，因为2003年，我们差点就赢了。我一直在说，2004年是属于我们的一年。游戏III。我们要把“甜蜜16强”带回来。2004年。我们做到了。我们赢了。我真的很高兴。
What am I going to guess for you? I can guess your age, weight, or birthday month.
我要猜你什么？我可以猜你的年龄、体重或生日月份。
Late morning, when I checked back at Games III, the pyramids of plush toys looked pretty much exactly as big as they had earlier that morning. Things were slow. And to goose the business, one of the supervisors, Sarah, was standing on the roof of this little hut.
深夜，当我回到“游戏III”确认时，毛绒玩具金字塔看起来几乎和当天早上摆好时一样大。生意很清淡。为了刺激生意，主管之一的萨拉正站在那个小屋的屋顶上。
88 more guesses--
再猜88次……
Beautiful.
太美了。
--until I'm coming--
……直到我……
Thank you.
谢谢。
--off the roof.
……从屋顶下来。
She's staying on the roof until--
她在屋顶上待着，直到……
I'm staying here for 100.
我待在这儿直到完成100次。
--she gets 100 guesses.
……她凑够100次猜测。
I'm here until I get 88 more guesses. And then I'm going to allow myself to take a bathroom break. So any of you guys walking by, if you guys want to come play my game, help me out, get me off this roof-- it's only $5 to play. I can guess your age, weight, or birthday month.
我在这儿直到凑够88次猜测。然后我就允许自己去上厕所。所以你们这些路过的人，如果想来玩我的游戏，帮帮我，让我从这屋顶下来吧——玩一次只要5美元。我可以猜你的年龄、体重或生日月份。
This is a technique that I recognize from 1,000 Public Radio pledge drives, and it was working about as slowly for her as it works for us. Strangers just don't care if some girl on the roof gets to take a bathroom break.
这是一种我从1000次公共广播募捐活动中识别出来的技巧，它对她来说效果和对我们来说一样慢。陌生人根本不在乎屋顶上的女孩能不能去上厕所。
I'm stuck here until I can get 88 more people to play. Seriously? And all you people don't want to help me out. Thanks. Peace. Thanks for the luck. You should come-- I dare you guys to come feel these turtles. It sounds like a weird thing, but we really have the softest turtles in town. You should feel one. They're really soft.
我被困在这儿，直到凑够88个人玩。真的吗？你们这些人都不想帮我一把。谢谢。再见。谢谢祝我好运。你们应该来……我敢打赌你们应该来摸摸这些乌龟。这听起来有点怪，但我们这儿真的是全城最软的乌龟。你应该摸一下。它们真的很软。
After a while, Sarah switched technique and finally managed to rustle up a crowd through the simple tactic of making a series of insanely terrible guesses. First, there is a dad who looks like he's 42 and, in fact, is 42. Sarah guesses 25. Then a grandmother, who is standing there with kids and grandkids-- Sarah writes her guess for this woman's age on a whiteboard.
过了一会儿，萨拉换了招数，终于通过制造一系列极其荒谬的猜测成功聚集了一群人。首先，有个爸爸看起来42岁，事实上也确实是42岁。萨拉猜25岁。然后是一位奶奶，和孩子孙子们站在一起——萨拉在白板上写下了她对这位女士年龄的猜测。
This could be really wrong. I get the feeling it's really wrong, but that's OK. We'll see. You guys like this guess? Maybe? All right. Turn around. How old are you?
这可能真的错了。我觉得这错得离谱，但没关系。我们等着看。你们喜欢这个猜测吗？也许吧？好了。转过来。你多大岁数？
I'm 52!
我52岁！
I guessed you're 37. It's sunglasses. Sunglasses really throw me off. But congratulations! You get to pick out any prize you want.
我猜你37岁。是太阳镜的问题。太阳镜真的让我看走眼了。但恭喜你！你可以挑任何你想要的奖品。
Later, Sarah privately confirmed for me that she did intentionally take a dive, which is fine with Cole, because it turns out it doesn't matter if the kids guess right. The game costs $5 to play. The prizes cost less than $5. Sarah can be wrong with every single guess, and they'd still make a nice profit. In fact, it's good to lose, because people carrying prizes around the park are a walking advertisement for all the games.
后来，萨拉私下向我证实，她确实是故意放水，这对科尔来说没关系，因为事实证明，孩子们猜对与否并不重要。游戏玩一次要5美元。奖品成本不到5美元。萨拉每次猜测都错，他们依然能赚到不错的利润。事实上，输了更好，因为人们在公园里带着奖品走动，就是所有游戏的活广告。
Cole's journey from summertime employee, like Sarah, to full-time, year-round boss happened in a couple of steps. He said, as a nerdy kid in high school in a small town, it was nice to come to a place where his personality was rewarded.
科尔从像萨拉这样的暑期工到全职全年老板的过程经历了几个阶段。他说，作为一个高中时在小镇里的书呆子，能来到一个性格受到奖赏的地方真是太好了。
I couldn't wait until the summer, because when it was summertime, I get to come to Worlds of Fun and work with people that are just like me, and enjoy our whole summer together.
我迫不及待地等到夏天，因为夏天的时候，我能来到“欢乐世界”，和跟我一模一样的人一起工作，一起享受整个夏天。
So after years of that, in his senior year at the University of Kansas at Lawrence, he got a phone call offering him the job of games manager. And he dropped out of school to take it.
所以在经历这些多年后，他在劳伦斯的堪萨斯大学上大四时，接到一个电话，提供了游戏经理的工作。他退学去接了这个工作。
It's probably one of the hardest decisions I've ever had to make. But I said, OK, this opportunity is probably only going to come along once in a lifetime.
这可能是我做过最艰难的决定之一。但我告诉自己，好吧，这个机会可能一生只有一次。
As you'd imagine, it hasn't been such a popular decision with the family.
你可以想象，这个决定在家里并不怎么受欢迎。
So I have a full year left. I'm one full year of college left. It comes up when you least expect it. It comes up when they-- like, "Oh, I know you're working real hard, but when are you getting back to school?" Or my grandmother-- "Now, before I pass on, you need to make sure that you've completed college"-- my grandma all the time. And I get it a lot from the girlfriend, too. "When are you going to finish?" Because she just graduated college.
我还有整整一年没上。我还剩最后一年大学。它在最意想不到的时候冒出来。它在他们……比如，“哦，我知道你工作很努力，但你什么时候回学校？”或者我祖母——“好了，在我去世前，你得确保你完成了大学学业”——我奶奶老这么说。我女朋友也经常这么说。“你什么时候才能读完？”因为她刚大学毕业。
This girlfriend and Cole are pretty serious. They just moved in together. They met in Games back in 2006, though she moved on from Games.
这位女朋友和科尔感情很深。他们刚搬到一起。他们在2006年的时候在“游戏部”认识的，尽管她后来离开了游戏部。
I get that all the time. She's like, "We're not going to be together forever if you don't finish college." I get it a lot.
我经常听到这个。她会说，“如果你不读完大学，我们不可能永远在一起。”我听得很多。
And how often will it come up?
这出现的频率有多高？
[SIGHS] Once a week-- maybe once every two weeks, depending on the week. I don't know. I don't know.
（叹气）每周一次——可能每两周一次，取决于那一周的情况。我不知道。我不知道。
Lots of very accomplished people don't have college degrees.
很多非常有成就的人都没有大学文凭。
I know.
我知道。
Steve Jobs.
史蒂夫·乔布斯。
Yeah. But Steve Jobs-- he changed the world. I'm just a lowly little games manager in a small mid-size park in Kansas City.
是啊。但史蒂夫·乔布斯——他改变了世界。我只是堪萨斯城一个中型公园里卑微的小游戏经理。
[BLOWS PAPER HORN] Who wants to play some games? Whoo!
（吹纸喇叭）谁想玩游戏？喔！
By midday, down in Games III, that is Dustin, who's wearing the full-body banana suit that Haley handmade for him, which looks amazing. But it is 94 degrees, which is sapping everybody's energy. And business is slow.
快到中午时，在“游戏III”区，那是达斯汀，他穿着海莉为他手工制作的全身香蕉装，看起来棒极了。但气温有94度，正在耗尽每个人的体力。生意很清淡。
Oh, all right. Well, hey, you guys have a great day.
哦，好的。好了，嘿，祝你们今天过得愉快。
Though, as the day wears on, people slowly migrate from the rides to the games. And by nightfall, when it cools off, the guys in Games II finally get Techno Ball working. Max and Okson are covered from head to toe in glow lights. Cole and I round a corner together, and we see them in the distance. And there's a crowd of three dozen people surrounding the game. It's fantastic.
不过，随着时间推移，人们慢慢从游乐设施转移到游戏区。入夜后，气温降下来，游戏II的家伙们终于让“电音球”运转起来。马克斯和奥克森从头到脚覆盖着发光灯。科尔和我一起转过一个拐角，在远处看到了他们。有三打人围着游戏。太棒了。
Oh my goodness. Oh, let's go look at Techno Ball. Look at this!
天哪。哦，我们去看“电音球”。看这个！
[TECHNO MUSIC PLAYING]
（播放电音舞曲）
[CHEERING AND SHOUTING]
（欢呼和尖叫）
No, it's six of your staff and--
不，那是你的六个员工和……
And two-- three other guys all dancing.
还有其他两个……三个伙计都在跳舞。
In a big circle-- four other guys.
围成一个大圈——还有四个伙计。
In a big cir-- yeah, four other guys all dancing in a big circle to techno music.
围成一个大……是啊，另外四个伙计都围成一个大圈随着电音跳舞。
And how many people are actually playing?
到底有多少人在玩游戏？
Zero. [LAUGHS] Hey, Dominic! Hey, Dom!
零个。（笑）嘿，多米尼克！嘿，多姆！
That's Dominic, the team leader here at Games II.
那是多米尼克，游戏II的领队。
Oh, look. Dom's all embarrassed. Hi, Dom.
哦，看。多姆害羞了。嗨，多姆。
What's up?
怎么了？
How many people are playing the game, Dom?
有多少人在玩游戏，多姆？
We're attracting a lot of attention.
我们吸引了很多注意。
Yeah. But why aren't we turning that into game play?
是啊。但为什么没把那转化为游戏参与呢？
Cole suggests, maybe they should dance inside the game instead of on the walkway in front of the game so people would be pulled in to play. Dom does not want to do this. And listen to what a good boss Cole is. He's firm, but he's very nice about it.
科尔建议，也许他们应该在游戏区里面跳，而不是在游戏区前的人行道上，这样人们才会被拉进来玩。多姆不想这样做。听听科尔是个多么好的老板。他很坚定，但对此处理得很温和。
You're so close.
你们离成功很近了。
I know.
我知道。
You're so close.
你们离成功很近了。
Do you see how much attention I just attracted?
你看到我刚才吸引了多少注意力吗？
It did! But then you didn't have anybody out here talking to them, saying, "Hey, why aren't you playing the game?"
确实！但你外面没安排人跟他们谈，说，“嘿，你们为什么不玩游戏？”
I know. But I was hoping that they would realize that.
我知道。但我希望他们自己会意识到。
No, no, no. They're not going to realize that. You know that. And better than anyone, you should know that. They're not going to just be like, "Oh." It looks fine. All the lights-- I'm not going to deny the awesomeness, but I am going to say that--
不，不，不。他们不会意识到。你知道这一点。而且比起任何人，你应该更清楚。他们不会只是觉得，“哦。”看起来不错。所有的灯光——我不会否认它的精彩，但我必须说……
No more dance parties.
别搞舞会了。
I really think the dance parties are not going to help you win.
我真的认为舞会不会帮你赢。
I walked down to check on Games III. It is 10:30 at night. Claire has been here for 13 hours since I saw her setting up pyramids of plush before the gates opened to the park. Those pyramids were now raggedy piles maybe half their original size, which means that they did great. They got lots of people to play. They've probably given away 500 prizes for wrong guesses. And Claire has had exactly the kind of day that Cole wants for all the kids.
我走去看看“游戏III”。现在是晚上10:30。克莱尔已经在公园开门前，我看到她设置毛绒金字塔后工作了13个小时。那些金字塔现在成了凌乱的堆叠，可能只有原始大小的一半，这意味着他们表现很棒。他们拉到了很多人玩。他们大概因为猜错年龄送出了500个奖品。克莱尔度过了科尔希望所有孩子都能度过的那种日子。
Did you have fun today?
你今天玩得开心吗？
Yes, I had a lot of fun. I had no idea what time it was until about 20 minutes ago when I checked. It just didn't occur to me that I needed to check the time.
是的，我玩得很开心。直到大约20分钟前我查看时间，我根本不知道现在几点了。我根本没想过需要看时间。
Because it was going by so fast?
因为过得太快了？
Yeah.
是啊。
When did you take your first break today?
你今天第一次休息是什么时候？
I haven't taken a break.
我还没休息过。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, I guess I'm used to it.
是啊，我想我习惯了。
This is Claire's third year here. She's 18, going to Missouri State in the fall to study nursing. And she tells me what a lot of kids here tell me. She wouldn't keep coming back to work at Worlds of Fun if not for Cole.
这是克莱尔在这里的第三年。她18岁，秋天要去密苏里州立大学读护理。她告诉我很多这里的孩子告诉我的一样。如果不是因为科尔，她不会一直回来“欢乐世界”工作。
Definitely not. I don't think any other boss would do the Rally Days, the Death Match, the Sweet 16, the Toss the Boss-- just all the fun stuff that we do that keeps us going through the season and just keeps this job exciting every day.
绝对不会。我不觉得有其他老板会搞“集会日”、“死斗”、“甜蜜16强”、“扔老板”——所有这些让我们在赛季中坚持下去，让这份工作每天都充满激情的有趣活动。
Sam, one of the leaders for Games IV, has been here for three summers. And he also says that Cole is the reason that he keeps coming back.
萨姆，“游戏IV”的领队之一，在这里待了三个夏天。他也说科尔是他一直回来的原因。
Honestly, no one else could do a better job. He was made to do this.
说实话，没人能做得更好。他天生就是干这个的。
It's funny watching him do something like sing a goofy song for you guys in the morning. You can imagine high school students and college students rolling their eyes at somebody doing that. But nobody does.
看着他早上给你们唱搞笑的歌挺有趣的。你可以想象高中生和大学生对着做这种事的人翻白眼。但没人这么做。
No, it's weird. It's almost like, that's the thing to do. Whatever Cole does is the thing to be doing at that moment. And we just all feel like that was the right move.
不，这很怪。几乎就像，那是必须做的事。无论科尔做什么，那一刻都是该做的事。我们都觉得那是正确的举动。
Do you remember what it was like the first time you saw one of his videos?
你还记得第一次看到他的视频是什么感觉吗？
I do. I remember seeing it, and I was like, that's my boss. And he just made that video. And it was so cool, because I went and even showed some of my friends. They were all like, who's this guy? It's like, that's my boss.
记得。我记得看到它，我心想，那是我的老板。他刚刚拍了那个视频。那太酷了，因为我去给朋友看，他们都说，这家伙是谁？我说，那是我的老板。
That's so weird, because a lot of people would say, well, it's an amusement park. You're great at working at an amusement park.
这太奇怪了，因为很多人会说，嗯，这只是个游乐园。你在游乐园工作很出色。
That doesn't mean, by the way, that he is seen by his bosses as some kind of superstar. He gets respect, sure. Everybody likes him. His immediate boss, Matt, thinks that there's nobody better at games in any of the 11 amusement parks owned by their parent company, Cedar Fair. But Cole is working at one of the smallest of the 11 parks. So other games managers at bigger parks bring in way more money than Cole does.
顺便说一句，这并不意味着他在老板眼里是什么超级巨星。他确实赢得了尊重。每个人都喜欢他。他的直属上司马特认为，在他们母公司“雪松会”拥有的11个游乐园中，没人比他更擅长游戏。但科尔所在的公园是11个公园中最小的之一。所以大型公园的游戏经理赚的钱比科尔多得多。
And games, in the grand scheme of things, is actually the smallest revenue producer at most amusement parks. The biggest money at an amusement park comes from ticket sales. Then there's food-- everybody buys food-- then merch. And then, bringing up the rear, is games. What Cole does has less effect on the company's bottom line than lots of people in the company. And as much as Cole loves this job, he can't help but wonder, how long can a person do this job?
在宏大的图景中，游戏部门其实是大多数游乐园收入来源最小的部分。游乐园最大的收入来自门票销售。然后是食物——每个人都买食物——然后是商品。最后才是游戏。科尔所做的对公司利润的影响力不如公司里的许多人。尽管科尔热爱这份工作，但他忍不住在想，一个人能干这份工作多久？
So the one thing that I always say is, I'm 25 now. I started here when I was 14. And the weird thing is, is that I'm getting older, but everybody else in the department-- staying the same age.
所以，我总是说的一件事是，我现在25岁了。我14岁开始在这里工作。奇怪的是，我老了，但部门里的每个人……岁数却没变。
All right. I'm going to stop the tape right there. Yes, I know. Matthew McConaughey, Dazed and Confused. Cole has seen the film, too.
好了。我就在那儿停掉录音。是的，我知道。《年少轻狂》里的马修·麦康纳。科尔也看过那部电影。
But the thing I'm wondering for you is, do you feel like somehow, accidentally, in this job, you got stuck in high school, you got stuck at 15? Like, there's a part of you where you're still back there?
但我对你好奇的一点是，你是否觉得在某种程度上，意外地，在这份工作中，你被困在了高中，困在了15岁？就像你身上有一个部分依然回到了过去？
I like working out in the park with the kids, absolutely. 100%.
我绝对喜欢和孩子们一起在公园里工作。百分之百喜欢。
The goofball part.
那个搞笑的部分。
The part where you get to act their age instead of your age.
那个你可以演他们的年纪而不是你自己年纪的部分。
Yes. Does that make me sound bad? I'm still a manager. I'm still overseeing 100 people that work for me. But at the same time, 10 years from now, I don't think I could still be a goofball. I think that'd just get creepy, [LAUGHS] you know? You're 35, and you work with a bunch of high schoolers in a-- is that creepy? Maybe. Maybe not. I don't know.
是的。那让我听起来很糟糕吗？我依然是个经理。我依然监管着为我工作的100个人。但同时，10年后，我不觉得我还能当个搞笑的人。我想那会变得令人毛骨悚然，（笑）你知道吗？你35岁了，和一群高中生在……那是令人毛骨悚然吗？也许吧。也许不是。我不知道。
Do you worry that you'll never be happier in any job than you are in this one?
你是否担心你以后永远不会比在这一份工作里更开心了？
Yes, absolutely.
是的，绝对会。
That's a weird fate-- to know that you're in the best job you may ever have at 25, especially when it's a job that you know in your heart-- that can't last.
这是一种奇怪的命运——在25岁就知道自己拥有了可能一生中最好的工作，尤其是当你知道这份工作……在心底里——无法持久时。
We first broadcast this story in 2011. Cole is now solidly in his 30s. He left his job at Worlds of Fun years ago, worked for a while in sales at a toy company, traveled a little, giving motivational talks about being a boss at an amusement park. Now he works in sales at a tech company. And he's a dad, which he loves-- really, really loves.
我们在2011年首次播出了这个故事。科尔现在已经稳稳地步入30岁了。几年前他离开了“欢乐世界”的工作，在一家玩具公司做了销售，旅行了一阵，做关于如何在游乐园当老板的励志演讲。现在他在一家科技公司做销售。他成了爸爸，他非常非常爱他的孩子。
Cole's still crazy about amusement parks. He actually helped set up an alumni association for his old staff at the games department, worked out a deal with Worlds of Fun to allow old games kids to go back to the park and work a shift in games, relive the glory. His latest project is figuring out how he can build a roller coaster in his backyard.
科尔依然对游乐园疯狂着迷。他其实为他的老部下们成立了一个游戏部校友会，和“欢乐世界”达成了一项协议，允许老游戏部的孩子们回到公园在游戏区工作一个班次，重温昔日的荣光。他最新的计划是研究如何在后院造一个过山车。
Well, coming up, carnies float in the air, scary things happen on rides, and bold steps forward for paintball targets everywhere. Our hour of amusement parks continues in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
好了，接下来，嘉年华艺人悬浮在空中，游乐设施上发生了可怕的事情，还有随处可见的彩弹射击目标的勇敢迈进。我们的游乐园小时节目将在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- amusement parks. It's July. It's hot. We wanted to go someplace fun here on the radio, someplace that lots of us, me included, would never visit today because of coronavirus. Today's show is a rerun, recorded before all that.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在节目中，我们都会选定一个主题，给你们带来关于那个主题的各种故事。今天的节目——游乐园。七月到了。天气很热。我们想去这儿电台里某个有趣的地方，一个因为冠状病毒，我们中间很多人（包括我）今天绝不会去的地方。今天的节目是重播，是在这一切发生之前录制的。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two-- Great Adventures. Well, we asked you, our listeners, to call in with your amusement park stories. Nearly 300 of you did. And one of our producers, Jane Marie, listened to all of those voicemail messages. She joins me now. Hey, Jane.
我们来到了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕——伟大的冒险。我们邀请了你们，我们的听众，打来电话分享游乐园的故事。你们中间有将近300人这么做了。我们的制片人之一，简·玛丽，听了所有那些语音留言。她现在加入了我们。嘿，简。
Hey.
嘿。
So Jane, trends, patterns? What can you tell me?
所以简，趋势、模式？你能告诉我什么？
Carnies.
嘉年华艺人。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah. There's creepy carnies, and hot carnies, and carnies that people married. And a bunch of people called and told stories about carnies making the ride go too fast or keeping them on the ride too long.
是啊。有令人毛骨悚然的嘉年华艺人，火辣的嘉年华艺人，还有人们嫁给的嘉年华艺人。很多人打来电话，讲了嘉年华艺人让游乐设施转得太快或者把人留在上面太久的故事。
Demonic carnies.
恶魔般的嘉年华艺人。
Yeah.
是啊。
OK, yeah.
好吧，是啊。
These two calls that I'm going to play are from Barry Silver and Penny Delaney Cothran. And they had the same exact crazy carnie story, only they happened years apart and in different cities. But it's fun to imagine they're talking about the same guy.
这两个我要播放的电话来自巴里·西尔弗和佩妮·德莱尼·科思兰。他们讲了同一个极其疯狂的嘉年华艺人故事，只是发生在不同年份、不同城市。但想象他们说的是同一个人很有趣。
(SUBJECT) PENNY DELANEY COTHRAN: My amusement park story involves the Gravitron.
（嘉宾）佩妮·德莱尼·科思兰：我的游乐园故事涉及“引力场”。
Yeah. Oh, let me interrupt real quick, because the Gravitron-- that was the most popular ride people talked about in the phone calls.
是啊。哦，让我打断一下，因为“引力场”——那是电话里人们谈论最多的游乐设施。
Huh.
呵。
That's the one where it's a cylinder, and you climb in it, and you put your back up against the inside wall of the cylinder--
就是那种圆筒状的，你爬进去，把背靠在圆筒内壁上……
Oh, right. And it spins around, and the floor drops out.
哦，对了。它转起来，地板就掉了。
Yep. And you're stuck to the wall.
是啊。你就被吸在墙上了。
(SUBJECT) PENNY DELANEY COTHRAN: There was a carnie there, and he was waving us all in. And we had purchased tickets. And I guess our first sign that this is going to be an interesting ride was when he said no to the tickets we offered him and just waved us in.
（嘉宾）佩妮·德莱尼·科思兰：那里有一个嘉年华艺人，他在招手让我们进去。我们买了票。我猜我们得到的第一个迹象就是这将会是一次有趣的体验，当他拒绝了我们递上的票，直接挥手让我们进去了。
I was working for the World of Wonder sideshow last month. I had made friends with the carnie who was running the Gravitron.
上个月我为“奇迹世界”杂耍表演工作。我和运营“引力场”的那个嘉年华艺人交了朋友。
(SUBJECT) PENNY DELANEY COTHRAN: He started up the ride, and the music was blaring. And I remember it was Motley Crue's "Dr. Feelgood."
（嘉宾）佩妮·德莱尼·科思兰：他启动了设施，音乐震耳欲聋。我记得那是莫特利克鲁乐队的《Dr. Feelgood》。
Anyway, he gave me a private showing where I'm riding inside this thing. Music's blasting.
不管怎么说，他给了我一次私人展示，我当时就在里面坐着。音乐在轰炸。
(SUBJECT) PENNY DELANEY COTHRAN: And the lights were going. And we were spinning around, and this centrifugal force was pushing us up against the wall. And the next thing I know, this carnie steps out from behind his operating box and comes out into the centrifuge, and proceeds to pull himself up and place his feet on the spinning wall and walk over the riders, step by step, with his body completely horizontal to the earth.
（嘉宾）佩妮·德莱尼·科思兰：灯光在闪烁。我们在旋转，向心力把我们推向墙壁。接下来我知道的是，这个嘉年华艺人从操作箱后面走出来，进入了离心机，接着拉起自己，双脚踩在旋转的墙壁上，一步一步地走过乘客，他的身体完全与大地平行。
He's standing on the wall next to me, surfing inside of the Gravitron. That's right, the ride operator left the control panel to start surfing the inside, parallel to the ground.
他站在我旁边的墙上，在“引力场”里冲浪。没错，设施操作员离开控制台开始在里面冲浪，与地面平行。
(SUBJECT) PENNY DELANEY COTHRAN: The force was holding his feet against the wall, and it was just the most amazing thing I'd ever seen.
（嘉宾）佩妮·德莱尼·科思兰：离心力把他的脚固定在墙上，那是我见过最神奇的事。
Best experience of my life.
我人生中最棒的体验。
So I know, because you told me right before we sat down, that a lot of the stories that people called in to tell were love stories.
所以我知道，因为在我们坐下来之前你告诉过我，人们打来分享的很多故事都是爱情故事。
Tons of love stories, or like-like stories.
无数爱情故事，或者是喜欢上了谁的故事。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Like, summer flings, summer romances, first kisses. There were people that lost their virginity on rides.
比如，夏日邂逅、夏日恋情、初吻。还有人在游乐设施上失去了童贞。
Ew.
额。
Yeah. Don't do that. But then there were the proposals. There were a lot of people proposing at amusement parks, some more successfully than others.
是啊。别那么做。但还有求婚。有很多人在游乐园求婚，有的成功，有的则不然。
My name is Natasha. And in May, my boyfriend proposed to me on a roller coaster. We were on a Viper. He said, "Will you marry me?" And he popped open the ring box. And the ring fell out of the box and down into the pits of Viper. It was pretty awful.
我叫娜塔莎。五月份，我男朋友在过山车上向我求婚。我们在“蝰蛇”号上。他说，“你愿意嫁给我吗？”他弹开了戒指盒。戒指从盒子里掉了出来，掉进了“蝰蛇”号的深坑里。那感觉真是太糟糕了。
I started trying to get the ride operator to stop the car. The director of operations at the park assembled a team of about 20 people, and they searched for the ring for hours. And that happened in May. So the kicker here is that that ring was actually my grandmother's ring, and they're actually still searching for it. We have yet to find it.
我开始试着让设施操作员停下车。公园运营总监召集了大约20人的团队，他们搜寻了戒指好几个小时。那是五月份发生的事。所以这里的残酷现实是，那枚戒指其实是我祖母的戒指，而他们其实还在找。我们至今还没找到。
So I called Natasha, actually, to see if they'd found it yet. And she said that the park had called her recently and said they found a ring. But it wasn't hers. There was another engagement ring.
所以我其实给娜塔莎打了电话，看他们找到了没有。她说公园最近给她打了电话，说他们找到了一枚戒指。但不是她的。那是另一枚订婚戒指。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Yep.
没错。
Well, it's good to know that her fiancé wasn't the only dummy.
嗯，知道她的未婚夫不是唯一的笨蛋感觉真好。
Right. And then we got a bunch of scary calls. So this is a scary one. Wendy in Austin, Texas-- she and her friend went to the fair. And they were getting on a roller coaster. It was one of those medium-sized fair roller coasters where there's one big drop and then a loop-de-loop. But as she was getting on, she was futzing around with her purse.
对。然后我们接到了很多恐慌的电话。这是一个恐怖的。得克萨斯州奥斯汀的温迪——她和朋友去了集市。她们要上过山车。那是那种中等规模的集市过山车，有一个大俯冲，然后一个大回环。但在她上去的时候，她正在摆弄她的钱包。
I reached up to pull the harness down over me, and it locked above my head. And I have nothing holding me into the roller coaster. So I look over in horror as the carnie guy that was running the ride looks at me, and he pushes the button to go, and the thing starts to go. And I'm telling him, wait, wait, wait! Stop, stop! I don't have my seat belt on!
我伸手去把安全扣拉下来覆盖住我，它锁在了我头顶上。我身上没有任何东西保护我坐在过山车里。所以我惊恐地看向运营设施的嘉年华艺人，他看着我，按下了前进按钮，设施开始移动。我告诉他，等等，等等，等等！停，停！我没扣上安全带！
But he doesn't stop. So--
但他没停。所以……
Oy.
噢。
I know. So now she's going up the hill. So she said she turned to her friend, and she just decided to wrap her arms and legs around her friend.
我知道。所以她正向上爬。她说她转向朋友，决定把手臂和腿缠在朋友身上。
Euh.
呃。
I know. And so they go down the hill, and then they go through the loop-de-loop.
我知道。然后她们俯冲下去，接着通过大回环。
So she's upside down?
所以她是倒过来的？
I know, just hanging onto her friend.
我知道，就挂在朋友身上。
As tight as I can, to stay inside the ride. And what really got scary is we whipped around the corners. I almost got thrown out, but I didn't.
抱得越紧越好，以留在游乐设施里。而真正恐怖的是我们猛冲过弯道的时候。我差点被甩出去，但我没被甩出去。
She said that she had whiplash for a week and that she was too young to realize that she probably could have sued them.
她说她脖子扭伤了一个星期，而且她当时太年轻，没意识到她本可以起诉他们。
Hm.
嗯。
So there's another story from this woman, Susan. Her 3-year-old wanted to go to the fair, but it was super late at night. And so they humored him, and they were like, sure, we'll take you. But they figured he would fall asleep on the way there. But he didn't. He stayed awake.
这儿还有另一个叫苏珊的女人的故事。她3岁大的孩子想去集市，但当时已经是深夜了。所以他们顺着他，他们想，好吧，我们带你去。但他们以为他在去那儿的路上就会睡着。但他没睡。他一直醒着。
So I said, OK, I'll take you in for one ride on the Ferris wheel, and then we'll go back to the car. My husband didn't even put his shoes on, because he didn't think he'd make it there. So we took him to the Ferris wheel, and he kept pointing to the Scrambler saying that he wanted to go on the Scrambler. And I said, no, no, no. And we got off the ride. I held the chain for the person behind me to come out. And when I turned back around, he was gone. We could not find him anywhere.
所以我说，好吧，我带你进去坐一次摩天轮，然后我们就回车里。我丈夫连鞋都没穿，因为他觉得孩子去不了那儿。所以我们带他去了摩天轮，他一直指着“乱舞机”说他想去坐。我说，不，不，不。然后我们下了设施。我帮后面的人拉着链条让他们出来。当我转过身，他不见了。我们到处都找不到他。
And as we're looking around-- and we have a whole group looking for this little three-year-old boy-- I looked up, and he was inside the gate of the Scrambler. And the Scrambler was going. His head was just at the car level. And the carnie woman stopped the ride, and she stopped it in time. She walked over, picked him up, handed him to me. She didn't say a word. And I took him. And he said, "She was really scary." And I said, "That woman was an angel." And so I will never bad-mouth a carnie again.
正当我们四处寻找——我们有一大群人都在找这个三岁的小男孩——我抬头一看，他进了“乱舞机”的大门。而“乱舞机”正在转。他的头正好就在车位水平高度。那名女嘉年华艺人停下了设施，她及时停住了。她走过来，抱起他，递给我。她一句话也没说。我接过他。他说，“她真的很吓人。”我说，“那位女士是个天使。”所以我再也不会诋毁嘉年华艺人了。
I'm glad we finally have some unequivocally pro-carnie material in this story.
我很高兴我们终于在这个故事里有了一些绝对支持嘉年华艺人的素材。
Me too.
我也是。
Hi. My amusement park story takes place in Disneyland. And I was really excited to go on the haunted house ride. I forget what it's called. Anyways, the door opens, and you are let into a room. And the door opens into a dark, empty room. And there is a person, a little-- little person. He was in the room already.
嗨。我的游乐园故事发生在迪士尼乐园。我真的很兴奋去坐那个闹鬼屋的设施。我忘了它叫什么了。不管怎样，门打开，你被放入一个房间。门开向一个黑暗、空旷的房间。那里有个人，一个很小的人。他已经在房间里了。
And I thought it was part of the haunted house, so I started screaming. And he was looking at me because I was screaming. And he was screaming at me. We were both screaming at each other. And then we both realized that it was not part of the haunted house and that we were just waiting in line with each other. And we pretended like nothing happened.
我以为那是闹鬼屋的一部分，所以我就开始尖叫。他看着我，因为我在尖叫。他也对我尖叫。我们俩都冲对方尖叫。然后我们俩都意识到那不是闹鬼屋的一部分，我们只是在和彼此排队。然后我们假装什么都没发生。
And finally, there were the puke stories.
最后，还有呕吐的故事。
Oh, a lot of people called about puke?
哦，很多人打来电话说呕吐的事？
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
And is the story more than just, I was on a ride, and I puked?
故事不仅仅是“我坐游乐设施，然后我吐了”吧？
Yeah. It's "I was on a ride and I puked," or "I was on a ride and I got puked on."
是啊。是“我坐游乐设施然后我吐了”，或者“我坐游乐设施然后被吐了一身”。
Well, I don't want to hear that. Wait, was there any that had a twist? Was it a surprise plot twist?
嗯，我不想听那个。等等，有哪个带反转的吗？有意外的情节反转吗？
The one that stands out for me is, this lady was on that Ocean Motion ride that's like a big boat that swings back and forth.
让我印象最深的是，这位女士坐在那个“海洋运动”设施上，就像一条来回摇摆的大船。
It basically just goes up and down--
它基本上就是上下起伏……
Yeah, just swings.
是啊，就是摇晃。
--and up and down, yeah.
……然后上下，是啊。
It's like a pendulum. And so she was up at the highest part of the boat, and she saw the guy on the other end of the boat start puking. And so then she was swinging down at the puke.
它像个钟摆。所以她在船的最高点，她看到船另一头的家伙开始呕吐。于是她就随着摇晃迎向了呕吐物。
Oh, no. And did she see the puke in midair--
哦，不。她是在半空中看到的呕吐物……
Yeah, like slow motion, coming--
是啊，像慢动作，过来……
--coming towards--
……冲向……
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I could see, in slow motion, this line of vomit coming towards me.
我能看到，像慢动作一样，这一线呕吐物向我飞来。
And it hit her?
然后喷到她身上了？
Yeah.
是啊。
Ew!
额！
About two seconds later, it splatters the entire right side of my body.
大约两秒钟后，它溅到了我身体的整个右侧。
There's nowhere to go! You can't get off the boat!
没地方躲了！你没法下船！
Jane Marie-- she used to be a producer here. These days, she is the host of the podcast The Dream, a show we really like. It's about multi-level marketing schemes and the people who get caught up in them. Act Three-- What I Didn't Do On My Summer Vacation. Sometimes, somebody ends up in an amusement park who really has no business there at all, who was not built to thrill at the thrills that the amusement park offers.
简·玛丽——她曾是我们这儿的制片人。现在，她是播客《梦》的主持人，我们很喜欢的节目。是关于多层次营销计划以及陷入其中的人们。第三幕——我暑假没做的事。有时，某人最后去了他们根本不应该去的游乐园，根本不是为了那些游乐设施提供的刺激而生的。
As a teenager, Jonathan Goldstein spent a summer working at an amusement park-- one that was situated right on the beach-- in Wildwood, New Jersey. It is your typical amusement park on the beach. There's a boardwalk, three wooden piers with roller coasters and a Ferris wheel, and lots of dropped popcorn and hot dog buns for the seagulls to eat. It's been 29 years since Jonathan went to work at Wildwood, and he always wanted to go back. And so we sent him, along with one of our producers, Jonathan Menjivar.
青少年时期，乔纳森·戈尔茨坦曾在一个游乐园工作——就在海滩边——在新泽西州的怀尔德伍德。那是典型的海滩游乐园。有一个木板路，三个有木制过山车和摩天轮的码头，还有很多海鸥吃掉的爆米花和热狗面包屑。距离乔纳森去怀尔德伍德工作已经29年了，他一直想回去。所以我们派他去了，陪同他的是我们的制片人之一，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔。
A quick note to listeners. This story has nothing explicit in it, but it does make reference to the existence of sex, as does this warning.
给听众的一个小提示。这个故事里没有任何露骨内容，但确实提到了性的存在，正如这个警告。
The smell of garbage is really bringing it all back in a rush. Maybe I could bring back a bag with some saltwater taffy.
垃圾的味道真的让一切扑面而来。也许我可以带一袋咸味太妃糖回来。
After a whole religious rebirth that I won't go into here, the summer of my 16th year found me seriously considering yeshiva, rabbinical school, for the fall. My rabbi suggested I spend the summer at this religious camp just to give me a better idea of what was to come.
在经历了一次我这里就不赘述的宗教重生后，16岁的那年夏天，我正认真考虑秋天去犹太经学院学习神职。我的拉比建议我在这个宗教营地待一个夏天，让我更好地了解未来。
But my best friend Evan said that summer camp was for suckers, and religious camp was even worse, and that if I came with him to Wildwood, he'd personally make sure I had a good time. "I'll get you L'ed really good," he wrote, like a blood oath in my 1986 high school yearbook. That's L'ed as in the letter L. And getting L'ed seemed important, especially if I was going to be giving my life over to the Torah, a text that placed greater emphasis on getting C'ed, as in circumcised. And so I went to Wildwood. And now, I was back.
但我最好的朋友埃文说夏令营是给傻瓜去的，宗教夏令营更是糟糕，如果我和他一起去怀尔德伍德，他会亲自确保我玩得开心。“我会让你彻底体验一次‘L’的滋味，”他写道，就像在我1986年的高中毕业纪念册上写的血誓一样。那是字母L的“L”。而体验一次“L”似乎很重要，特别是如果我要把一生献给托拉，那是一本更强调体验“C”（如割礼）的文本。于是我去了怀尔德伍德。现在，我又回来了。
How close did you live to the pier?
你离码头住得有多近？
As you've seen getting here, my sense of direction isn't my forte. Man, it's like the whole summer I was just floating around in a jar of formaldehyde.
就像你来到这里看到的，方向感不是我的长项。天哪，那整个夏天我感觉就像飘在一罐甲醛里。
The plan was to go down and get jobs. It was what a lot of teenagers in my town did. Evan's older brother had done it years earlier and had arranged a job for Evan handing out darts to patsies eager to pop balloons on the boardwalk. And I was supposed to get a job, too.
计划是过去找工作。这是我们镇上很多青少年做的事。埃文的哥哥多年前这么干过，并为埃文安排了一份在木板路上给那些想射气球的冤大头递飞镖的工作。我也应该找份工作。
But on our fourth night there, still without work, I sat on the edge of my bed and felt that sense of being a failure. This feeling would eventually become a staple in my life, something I'd grow comfortable with in bars, gyms, offices, and bedrooms. But just then, the feeling was strange and new, and I didn't quite know what to do with it.
但在那儿的第四个晚上，还是没找到工作，我坐在床边感到了失败感。这种感觉最终成了我生命中的必需品，在酒吧、健身房、办公室和卧室里我都能舒适地面对。但当时，这种感觉既奇怪又新鲜，我不知道该拿它怎么办。
We lived in a co-ed boarding house run by a woman with a face like a clenched fist named Mrs. D. I spent my days hanging out at Evan's balloon stand, where his boss finally became so tired of having me around that he pulled some strings to get me a job working as a change boy at an arcade. If you walk down the boardwalk, there was a point where it looked like the fun had come to an end. My arcade was just a few yards past that.
我们住在一个男女混住的寄宿公寓，由一个长得像紧握拳头的女人D太太经营。我白天都在埃文的气球摊闲逛，他的老板最终被我搞得厌烦透了，于是他走后门帮我在一个游戏厅找了份当换币员的工作。如果你沿着木板路走，有一个点看起来乐趣已经结束了。我的游戏厅就在那儿几码之外。
Do you remember where on the pier--
你记得在码头的哪里……
Yeah--
是啊……
--you were?
……你工作吗？
--that's what I'm thinking. I'm-- I think-- if anything, maybe that little shack right over there was the arcade, where there's a roller coaster going over it now. It's like the little house that Alvy Singer grew up in in Annie Hall.
……这就是我在想的。我……我想……如果有的话，也许那边那个小棚子就是那个游戏厅，现在过山车从它上面穿过。它就像伍迪·艾伦在《安妮·霍尔》里长大的那个小房子。
You've still got pizza parlors, games with unwinnable prizes, and the vague threat of violence about to erupt. In other words, Wildwood hadn't changed much. Back then, everything looked like 1986. Now? 1987. Though, as it turns out, the arcade I worked at is long gone.
你依然有比萨店，有充满赢不到的奖品的游戏，还有即将爆发的暴力威胁。换句话说，怀尔德伍德没怎么变。那时候，一切看起来都像1986年。现在？1987年。尽管事实证明，我工作的游戏厅早已不在了。
Even at the time, all the other arcades were carpeted and air-conditioned. But mine was like an outhouse with all the oldest, skankiest games, all their joysticks having had the joy jerked right out of them years earlier. On the 4th of July, I remember watching the fireworks through a little crack in the wall right above the Donkey Kong machine. I felt like a young Tony Montana just having come to America, except the only person I wanted to kill was myself.
即使在当时，所有其他的游戏厅都铺了地毯还有空调。但我那个就像个茅坑，摆满了最老、最破的游戏机，摇杆里几年前的快乐早已被 jerked 出来。在7月4日，我记得透过墙上的一个小裂缝，就在大金刚机器上方看着烟花。我感觉自己像个年轻的托尼·蒙大拿刚刚来到美国，除了我唯一想杀的人是自己。
Being a human change machine is just one of the jobs that seems only to exist on the boardwalk, like the guy who's paid to dance in front of the T-shirt shop to draw customers or the girl who blows bubbles all day outside a souvenir store.
当一个人形换币机只是那些似乎只存在于木板路上的工作之一，比如那个为了拉客而在T恤店前跳舞的家伙，或者在礼品店外整天吹泡泡的女孩。
Yes, that's my job. I take money from them.
是的，那就是我的工作。我从他们那儿收钱。
That's your whole job, is just blowing bubbles?
你整个工作就是一直吹泡泡？
That's only. And shine with laser.
仅仅是。还有用激光闪。
Shine a laser in people's eyes?
把激光射进人们的眼睛里？
No. No, of course.
不。不，当然不是。
The bubble girl tells me she is from Bulgaria. The Bulgarian bubble girl is very young-looking-- like, "first time away from home" young. And as she explains to me her work responsibilities, she is approached by a man who turns out to be her boss. He plants a big kiss on her cheek, as though marking his territory.
吹泡泡的女孩告诉我她来自保加利亚。那个保加利亚女孩看起来很年轻——那种“第一次离家”的年轻。当她向我解释她的工作职责时，一个男人走近她，那是她的老板。他在她脸颊上重重地亲了一下，就像在宣示领地。
Is it a good summer?
是一个美好的夏天吗？
Yeah, it's all right. It's all right. This boardwalk's getting bad. At nighttime, this boardwalk is bad.
是的，还好。还好。这木板路变得越来越坏了。夜里，这条木板路很糟糕。
What do you mean? Like--
什么意思？比如……
Like, bad fights and people stabbing people and shooting people. Yeah. You go two blocks off the boardwalk, there was a shooting and stabbing the other day.
比如，坏的打架，人们捅人、枪杀人。是啊。你离开木板路走两个街区，前几天就发生了枪击和捅人事件。
Holy cow.
天哪。
It's worse under the boardwalk. [LAUGHS]
木板路下面更糟。（笑）
What goes on under the boardwalk?
木板路下面发生了什么？
Oh, sex and drugs. I park underneath my store, and you can see underneath it here. And you catch them all the time down under there. They go right down them steps, and right underneath the boardwalk.
哦，性和毒品。我把车停在我的店下面，你可以在这儿看到下面。你总是能在那儿底下抓到他们。他们直接从那梯子下去，就在木板路下面。
What?
什么？
Wow.
哇。
Sex under the boardwalk.
在木板路下发生性行为。
Cool.
酷。
Me and you.
我和你。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah. You want to do it?
是啊。你想做吗？
No.
不。
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
Yep. All right. See you later. Oh, boy. That was creepy.
没错。好了。回头见。哦，天哪。那真是太令人毛骨悚然了。
My old boss, Mike, was creepy, too. Mike always wore sunglasses and a red, skintight bathing suit that, for some reason I could never quite fathom, always appeared to be wet. My friend Evan said that it was unwholesome how Mike's arms were so short. "He's like a T-Rex," Evan said. The first time Mike paid me, he had to get all crooked to get his wallet out.
我的老老板迈克，也很令人毛骨悚然。迈克总是戴着太阳镜，穿着一条红色的、紧身泳裤，出于某种我无法理解的原因，看起来总是湿的。我朋友埃文说迈克的手臂太短了，这很不健康。“他像个霸王龙，”埃文说。迈克第一次给我钱时，他得扭曲着身体才能掏出钱包。
Most of the time, I was in the arcade all by myself, and hardly anyone ever came in-- just little kids who sat on the ancient skee ball machines asking for free games. Those old skee ball machines haven't really changed.
大多数时候，我一个人在游戏厅里，几乎没人进来——只有小孩子坐在古老的滚球机器上要求免费游戏。那些老滚球机器其实没怎么变。
[ARCADE MACHINE MUSIC PLAYING]
（播放游戏厅音乐）
Now, my technique used to be, I'd do a sort of bank shot. There was this sweet spot that I would hit on the right bank.
现在，我以前的技巧是，我会做一个类似于库带球的方法。在右边的库带上有一个我可以击中的甜点。
[BALL ROLLING]
（球滚动声）
That was really close, wasn't it?
刚才真的很接近，不是吗？
You got the lowest amount of points you can get.
你得到了最低分。
You're like my son that I'm taking out trying to-- "You got the lowest one, dad." That little beer cozy is going to be mine. No longer will my hand have to be so frigid when I'm drinking a Budweiser.
你就像我带出去想……的儿子，“你得了最低分，爸爸。”那个啤酒保暖套会是我的了。当我喝百威啤酒时，我的手再也不用那么冰冷了。
[BALL ROLLING]
（球滚动声）
Mike was an alcoholic, and he left me to open and close the place most of the time. Sometimes he would stagger in in the middle of the afternoon and lay down on the lopsided pool table. Once comfortably spread out, he'd ask me to cover him from head to toe with the stuffed animals for skee ball so he could sleep without getting caught by the old woman who ran the pier. Every time I put Mike to bed, I became more and more convinced that yeshiva was the place for me.
迈克是个酒鬼，他大部分时间都让我开门和关门。有时他会在下午中间摇摇晃晃地进来，躺在倾斜的台球桌上。一旦舒服地躺好，他就会让我用滚球机的毛绒动物把他从头到脚覆盖起来，这样他就可以睡觉而不会被那个管理码头的老太婆抓到。每次我帮迈克入睡，我就越发坚定地相信，犹太经学院才是适合我的地方。
When he wasn't goofing off drunk, Mike was furthering Evan's work of trying to get me L'ed. He would invite Nancy, the 19-year-old redhead who ran the water squirt game next door, over so he could tell her about how she should "devirginalize" me. Nancy was a Jersey girl who wore low-backed shirts that showed off a large, complicated dragon tattoo. She told me it was a Chinese wind god and that an old biker boyfriend had given it to her. It started at her neck and slithered all the way down into her pants to blow across the tundra.
当他不醉醺醺地偷懒时，迈克就在推动埃文让我体验“L”滋味的计划。他会邀请住在隔壁经营水枪游戏的19岁红发女孩南希过来，这样他就可以告诉她应该如何让我“脱去处子之身”。南希是个泽西女孩，穿着低背衬衫，露出一个大而复杂的龙纹身。她告诉我那是中国风神，一个骑摩托车的老前男友给她的。它从她脖子开始，一路滑进裤子里，吹过冻土层。
In the afternoon, when business was slow, Nancy would come by and tell me about how Mike had just been over pleading on my behalf, and how she tried to explain to him that "We was just friends, right?" "Oh, yeah," I'd say, swallowing back the hard lump of foul-tasting virgin tears congealing in my throat. "The best."
下午生意清淡时，南希会过来告诉我迈克刚才还在如何为我求情，而她是如何试着向他解释“我们只是朋友，对吧？”“哦，是啊，”我说，咽下喉咙里积聚的污秽且令人窒息的处男之泪。“最好的那种。”
(SUBJECT) WOMAN (ON SPEAKER): Watch the tram car, please.
（演讲者）女士：请看好电车，谢谢。
When you listen to this music, don't you feel like you're going to round the corner and you're going to see, like, Joe Pesci beating someone to death with a baseball bat? That's all I could think about. It's a song called "Wildwood Days." Do you hear it? "Wildwood Days and Wildwood Nights."
当你听这首歌时，你不觉得你会转过弯，看到像乔·派西那样用棒球棍把某人打死吗？我只能想到这个。这是一首叫《怀尔德伍德日子》的歌。听见了吗？“怀尔德伍德日子，怀尔德伍德之夜。”
Yeah.
是啊。
[MUSIC - "WILDWOOD DAYS" BY BOBBY RYDELL]
（音乐 - 鲍比·莱德尔的《Wildwood Days》）
(SINGING) Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, those Wildwood days.
（歌唱）哇，哇，哇，哇，那些怀尔德伍德的日子。
My producer Jonathan and I walk down the boardwalk, where we discover what's got to be the very worst job in Wildwood.
我的制片人乔纳森和我沿着木板路走，我们发现了怀尔德伍德最糟糕的工作。
(SUBJECT) DUTZ BONUS, JR.: Most of the stuff I do is just off the top of my head. It's whatever I can pick up on the spot.
（嘉宾）杜茨·博纳斯，二世：我做的绝大部分事情都是即兴发挥的。随手捡起什么就是什么。
[POPPING]
（爆破声）
This is Dutz Bonus, Jr. The sounds you hear are people shooting at him with guns. Dutz Bonus, Jr. is a human paintball target. He shuffles back and forth and eggs on the crowd while being splattered like a Jackson Pollock canvas.
这是杜茨·博纳斯，二世。你听到的声音是人们用枪向他射击。杜茨·博纳斯，二世是一个人体彩弹目标。他在被泼洒得像杰克逊·波洛克的画布一样时，还在人群中左右摇晃并起哄。
(SUBJECT) DUTZ BONUS, JR.: [CHUCKLES] I'll put it as blunt as I can, because this is how it is on my tax forms, too. I'm an entertainer-- not the dancer kind. But basically, I get suited up in hockey gear, and I get shot at all night.
（嘉宾）杜茨·博纳斯，二世：（轻笑）我直白点说吧，因为我的税表上也是这么写的。我是个艺人——不是跳舞那种。但基本上，我穿着冰球装备，整晚被人射击。
And it doesn't start to get to you a little bit? Do you dream about it?
这不会让你觉得有点不舒服吗？你会梦到它吗？
(SUBJECT) DUTZ BONUS, JR.: No, I love it. It's entertaining to me, because this is one of the jobs that I can be as creative as I want to be. And it's just like web page design. When you go in, you can do whatever you want.
（嘉宾）杜茨·博纳斯，二世：不，我爱死它了。这对我来说很有趣，因为这是我可以尽情发挥创意的工作之一。就像网页设计。当你进去的时候，你可以做任何你想做的事。
Before Dutz, human paintball targets simply shuffled from side to side, holding a shield. Then, one day, Dutz dropped his shield and began to moonwalk. Soulja Boy was to follow. He also invented shadowboxing at the paintballs and running towards the shooters. Dutz is protected by a suit that looks like what you'd come up with if you tried to build a Michelin Man costume out of moist newspaper and epoxy glue.
在杜茨之前，人体彩弹目标只是举着盾牌左右摇晃。有一天，杜茨扔掉了盾牌开始跳太空步。索尔贾小子紧随其后。他还发明了对着彩弹投球的影子拳击和冲向射击者。杜茨穿的盔甲看起来就像你试图用潮湿报纸和环氧树脂造出的米其林轮胎人服装。
So people are armed with paintball guns?
所以人们配备了彩弹枪？
(SUBJECT) DUTZ BONUS, JR.: Yeah, that we provide, because a lot of people try to-- they want to bring their own, but we don't allow that. It's just not going to happen.
（嘉宾）杜茨·博纳斯，二世：是啊，我们提供的，因为很多人想……他们想自带，但我们不允许。这是不可能发生的。
So the suit that you wear protects you from any pain?
所以你穿的衣服能保护你免受伤害？
(SUBJECT) DUTZ BONUS, JR.: For the most part, yeah. There's some weak spots. But I can't say where the weak spots are, because then a lot of people will find out. And then it becomes a little dangerous.
（嘉宾）杜茨·博纳斯，二世：大部分情况下，是的。有一些薄弱点。但我不能说哪里是薄弱点，因为那样很多人就会知道。然后它就变得有点危险了。
Before agreeing to talk with me, Dutz wanted to finish his break with the woman who works next door at the old-timey photo place. As it turns out, she's his wife, who he met on this very boardwalk. Dutz might spend his day getting fired at in a cage. But at least, on his time off, he has someone to talk to, someone with whom to share the secret weak spots in his armor.
在同意和我交谈之前，杜茨想和在隔壁老式照相店工作的女人结束休息时间。事实证明，那是他的妻子，他们就是在木板路上相识的。杜茨可能整天在笼子里被人射击。但至少在他休息的时候，他有人可以交谈，有人可以分享他盔甲上的秘密薄弱点。
Back when I lived there, Wildwood had this reputation for being a big party town. People were supposed to be scoring like nuts on the boardwalk every night. And actually, they were. The only real action I got that summer, though, was in the form of a single kiss. I later referred to it as the kiss that ruined my summer.
我住在那儿的时候，怀尔德伍德有个大派对之城的名声。人们本该每晚在木板路上像疯了一样得分。事实上，确实如此。我那个夏天唯一真正的行动，是以一个吻的形式。我后来称之为毁了我那个夏天的吻。
It happened while I was out walking on the boardwalk late one night. I saw a group of older girls, maybe in their early 20s, coming toward me. One of them, a little ahead of the others, was spinning with her arms stuck out and her long, blonde hair all over the place. Just as she got right up close to me, she grabbed the back of my neck and put her lips right on mine.
那发生在我深夜在木板路上走路时。我看到一群大女孩，可能20出头，向我走来。其中一个走在最前面，手臂伸着，金发乱蓬蓬地在转圈。就在她靠近我时，她抓住了我的后脖子，把嘴唇贴在我嘴唇上。
I remember, as she pulled back, I spastically grabbed onto her wrist. I didn't want her to leave. Her friends had to pry my fingers off, one at a time, as she stood there smiling at me all stoned and airy. That night, back at the boarding house in our room, I spent the rest of the evening obsessing, as it might have been the last one I'd receive until I got married. That kiss pretty much felt like my swinging bachelorhood. In yeshiva, I'd be the mysterious one with a past.
我记得当她撤回时，我像痉挛一样抓住了她的手腕。我不想让她走。她的朋友们不得不一个一个把我手指掰开，而她站在那儿，神志不清地对着我笑。那天晚上，回到寄宿公寓我们的房间里，我花了一整晚沉迷于此，因为那可能是直到我结婚前我收到的最后一个吻。那个吻感觉就像我结束的单身汉生活。在犹太经学院，我将是那个有过去的神秘人。
For the rest of the summer, I couldn't pass a woman on the boardwalk without thinking that we should somehow be meeting in a kiss, that that's how life should really be. It turned walking along the boardwalk into a relentless drizzle of small but horrible disappointments.
在那之后的整个夏天，我走在木板路上，无法不想到我们应该以某种方式在接吻中相遇，那才是生活真正的样子。它把沿着木板路行走变成了一场无休止的、微小但可怕的失望。
I didn't know it then, but that summer would prove the best one I'd have as a teenager. Even though I was worked like an indentured servant, giving every penny of my earnings to Mrs. D, even though I made no friends, and even though I only made it to the beach but once, where I sat on a mildewy boarding house washcloth, exhausted and pale, that whole summer felt like some big, fat vacation, just because I was 16 and away from my parents for the first time.
我当时不知道，但那个夏天将是我作为青少年度过的最好的一个夏天。即使我被当成契约奴工对待，把每一分赚的钱都交给D太太，即使我没交到任何朋友，即使我只有一次去海滩，坐在发霉的寄宿公寓洗脸巾上，精疲力竭且面色苍白，但整个夏天都感觉像一场盛大的、丰满的假期，只因为我16岁，第一次离开父母。
When I got back home, I didn't end up going to yeshiva. I didn't bring home any pen pals, money, or happy, romantic memories. But I did bring back a pair of black pants covered in small, white skulls. They were really baggy, and I had to wear them with 10-inch cuffs at the bottom. But when I showed up for my first day back at school, I thought I looked really punk rock. I thought, like anyone who'd never been L'ed, that they were the pants of someone who got L'ed all summer long.
当我回到家，我没去犹太经学院。我没带回任何笔友、钱或快乐的浪漫记忆。但我确实带回了一条布满小白骷髅的黑色裤子。它们很宽松，我不得不在底端卷起10英寸的袖口。但当我第一天回校上课时，我觉得我看起来真的很朋克。我心想，像任何没体验过“L”的人一样，它们就是那个夏天一直体验“L”的人穿的裤子。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the podcast Heavyweight. Check it out on Spotify or whatever you get your podcasts. There's a list of their best, favorite episodes. Just search "Heavyweight Starter Kit" on Spotify.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是播客《重量级》的主持人。在Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方看看。那里有他们最喜欢、最棒的剧集列表。在Spotify上搜索“重量级入门套件”即可。
A lot of winners today?
今天有很多赢家吗？
Everybody wins.
每个人都赢。
Do you have, like, a patter? What would you say to get a guy like me to come over?
你有什么……窍门吗？你会说什么来让像我这样的家伙过来？
I don't know if I would call you in. You don't look like the type of guy that would spend money here, you know? You get three shots for five--
我不知道我会不会叫你过来。你看起来不像那种会在这儿花钱的家伙，你知道吗？三枪5美元……
Was he saying that I'm too cool a customer, or was he saying, "You're too cheap a Jew?"
他是在说我很冷静，还是在说，“你是个吝啬的犹太佬？”
[MUSIC - "ROLLER COASTER BY THE SEA" BY JONATHAN RICHMAN AND THE MODERN LOVERS]
（音乐 - 乔纳森·里奇曼和现代恋人乐团的《Roller Coaster by the Sea》）
(SINGING) You see, I went on the roller coaster last night when I was feeling bad, down by the sea in Santa Cruz, and I was feeling sad. But we went down and around, and it knocked me out of my head.
（歌唱）你看，昨晚我感觉糟糕时去了过山车，就在圣克鲁兹海边，我感到悲伤。但我们顺流而下，它把我从头脑中震了出来。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Marie and me, with Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production help on this rerun from Nora Gill, Catherine Raimondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由简·玛丽和我制作，有本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·凯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。本重播的制作帮助来自诺拉·吉尔、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。
Special thanks today to Bill Childs, Dave Althoff, Kim Martin, Jeff Potts, Dave Dickerson, Amy Silverman, Lindsey Young at Morey's Pier in Wildwood, New Jersey. Original music scoring in Act One of our show by Dave Hill, featuring Dave Hill on guitar. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, whose turtle breeding experiments are finally paying off.
特别感谢今天帮助的比尔·查尔兹、戴夫·奥尔索夫、金·马丁、杰夫·波茨、戴夫·迪克森、艾米·西尔弗曼，以及新泽西州怀尔德伍德莫里码头的琳赛·杨。节目第一幕的原创音乐由戴夫·希尔编曲，并由戴夫·希尔演奏吉他。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他的乌龟繁殖实验终于有了回报。
I dare you guys to come feel these turtles. It sounds like a weird thing, but we really have the softest turtles in town. You should feel one. They're really soft.
我敢打赌你们应该来摸摸这些乌龟。这听起来有点怪，但我们这儿真的是全城最软的乌龟。你应该摸一下。它们真的很软。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "ROLLER COASTER BY THE SEA" BY JONATHAN RICHMAN AND THE MODERN LOVERS]
（音乐 - 乔纳森·里奇曼和现代恋人乐团的《Roller Coaster by the Sea》）
(SINGING) Roller coaster by the water, you made me feel more as I ought to, whoa, whoa. Yes, you knocked me out of my head.
（歌唱）海边的过山车，你让我感觉比我应得的更多，哇，哇。是的，你把我从头脑中震了出来。